SPEAKER: Alerting is vital
to quickly notify you
of any problems in
your application.
Cloud monitoring lets you
set up custom alerting,
but it's important to set
up alerting correctly.
Let's go over how you
can set up alerting,
and then look at
some common mistakes
and learn how to avoid them.
Alerts provide timely awareness
of operational problems
in your cloud applications, so
you can resolve the problems
quickly.
For example, you may
have a system that's
having higher latency
than expected,
or your production
environment might
run into a resource constraint.
Here, we can see an
actual notification email
from an alert
based on CPU usage.
This email shows
key information,
such as what triggered
the alert, which project
it's in, and when it happened.
When you create an
alerting policy,
you'll need to
describe the conditions
under which you
want to be alerted
and how you want to be notified.
This includes identifying
the metrics and values
that the alert will trigger on.
Metrics can come from your
Google Cloud Services,
such as Compute Engine or GKE.
You can also alert
on metrics that
come from your uptime
checks or SLOs.
Notifications for
an alert can be
sent to multiple channels,
like email, SMS, or pub/sub.
Adding multiple
notification channels
makes sure everyone
can be notified,
no matter which
tools they're using.
Now, let's look at how to avoid
some common mistakes teams
make when setting up alerts.
The key to useful
alerts is timeliness.
Some metrics may lag
behind actual usage
due to ingestion delays.
This means they may not be as
useful for production alerts.
For example, we can
see a few metrics here
that are sampled
every 60 seconds,
but could take up to six
hours to actually report.
If you want an alert on
these types of metrics,
you'd better make sure that you
can tolerate the potential wait
time.
Another common mistake
is using the wrong kinds
of metrics and alerts.
There are three types of
metrics and five types of data
that can be used, and
it's important to know
when to use each.
Types of metrics you can
use are gauge metrics,
where the value represents
a specific instance in time.
A common example is
measuring CPU utilization
at any point in time.
Delta metrics, where the value
measures the change since it
was last recorded.
One example would be
measuring the change
in requests for an API.
And cumulative metrics, where
the value increases over time.
A great example of this
is compute usage time.
It's important to read the
full details on each metric
and choose the right ones
to match what you need.
Not every type of metric
can use every type of value.
In addition, cumulative
metrics can't
be used for alerting without
first being aggregated
into noncumulative metrics.
It's also important
to understand
the two stages of data
aggregation, alignment
and reduction.
Alignment aggregates your data
within a single time series
by bucketing unaligned data into
alignment periods, or windows.
You can then choose
different functions
to calculate a single value
aligned to a minute boundary,
such as sum, average, or max.
Reduction then further
aggregates that data
by grouping the
data across labels.
For example, you may align
your latency metric value
to hourly buckets using
the maximum value,
and then reduce by
regional labels.
That would give you
the maximum latency
per region for each hour.
Just like the types
of metrics, you'll
want to make sure that
you're aggregating data
in the way that makes
the most sense for what
you're trying to measure.
In addition to that,
here are two best
practices to make
sure you follow.
First, the alignment
period should always
be greater than or equal to
your metrics delay time window.
Otherwise, your window might
not have any data in it
due to the delay.
Second, make sure you're using
multiple conditions correctly.
Choosing Any means
only one condition
needs to be met for your
alert, while choosing All
means every condition
has to be met.
Check out the
documentation to see
more examples and
additional details
about alerting and metrics.
[MUSIC PLAYING]